[Music]  my name is david funiel i come from  spain i'm married i have three children  and two cats i work as a program officer  in dg connect in the unit of robotics  and artificial intelligence  [Music]  i would say that the most satisfying  part is when you finish a project and  you see the results of that we are  talking about the latest technology it  means that we are discovering things and  put it down in the stage of development  that might be something marketable in  four or five  [Music]  you years develop yourself so much here  as you can do in the private company you  can have a lot of chances of even moving  between different domains within the  commission  if you believe in europe and project  this is the best place to be because you  can really make an impact  [Music]  internet  [Music]